fake news plagues not only politics but
the scientific world with new technology
now part of our daily lives it's
essential to trust that the information
we're getting is correct that's
particularly true in the scientific
field which can be highly complex if I
have to think of one example of this
information in science I would go back
to 2008 where you had the launch of the
LHC the CERN accelerator and people were
fearing at the time that it would create
small black holes that would swallow the
earth according to recent survey 80% of
European citizens have already come
across false or misleading information
online at least several times a month
this crisis of confidence worries the
European Parliament a negative message
can actually become viral very fast we
realize we need to respond to that by
making sure that citizens will have the
option to another another truth or what
we consider to be scientific based
evidence in June 2018 the European
Parliament's panel for the future of
Science and Technology launched the
European science media hub a platform
designed to inform educate and bring
together journalists scientists and
political decision makers the idea is to
improve journalist tools for knowledge
information checking and for networking
with scientists
it also offers to political
decision-makers a point of contact to
exchange views we science journalists
cover
science which has become very
international and we also cover
industries corporations which are also
very international and politics which
has become European so we absolutely
need to network internationally to
tackle the big challenges of our job and
this media hub can help us do that the
European science media hub and science
journalists give European citizens a
credible information from verified
sources it will also want to tear the
most searched-for scientific subjects
online and in the press showing trends
with the public it's a crucial step
towards a healthy
access to information